foreign
is waiting for us there Alan how can we
help
hey guys it's a pleasure to talk to you
you bet
so
I cheer all the time
don't finance a rental property
so I have been diligently saving and I'm
about ready to I think pull the trigger
on getting a rental the problem is I
would like to hear you guys opinion on
how to like structure setting out myself
for Success when it comes to
you know doing this as a business how
much money have you got saved
um about
170 000 and what are you looking at
buying
that's that's why I'm calling actually
all right so I was going to see sort of
deal recommend something like
multi-family or single family something
that you know multi-families are cheaper
but harder to sell from what I have
noticed online
you know how do you how do you recommend
taking next steps as opposed to uh you
know for the structuring of the deal as
opposed to just the financing side
yeah I mean I think it's I think it's a
great question and real estate is
something that you know we talk about a
lot on this show is just another Avenue
to Building Wealth and I know the you
know one of the best ways that you're
going to just make money in general Alan
because we look at real estate
specifically I should say we within the
Ramsay family the way that I've seen it
always kind of the the viewpoint on it
is that it is it is a long-term play
that you're not gonna you know you're
not gonna be getting rich off of the
rentals that you're getting every month
it really is a it's an equity play uh
it's even a play to say hey we're gonna
keep this for decades and even pass it
on you know maybe to my kids you know so
like there's it's a long-term play is
that what you're kind of is that your
mindset or is this is it more hey I want
to get into something flip it maybe make
some money on it but I'm gonna do it
with cash because there's two ways to do
it not you know neither one's right or
wrong I'm just curious what your mindset
is
well my mindset is I want to buy
something that I can get into and I plan
on holding for a long time now whether
that's TurnKey whether for somebody to
move in or I need to fix it up because I
personally like doing that kind of work
myself yeah that would be the that would
be the play but things like should I set
up an LLC for a property should I just
do this under my name like what do you
guys recommend on that front well before
we get into that piece uh do you have
any debt
I do not okay no do you have three to
six months
20 years what baby step are you on what
got through college without that I guess
uh
I guess that'd be four five and six good
um I'm kind of a mix I guess because is
your primary home paid off Alan
uh yeah I bought it as a as a wow really
cheap houses yeah so what does what does
170 get you in Amarillo assuming that
you're paying cash
right
um you're starting to get into a market
that is good three two property not in
the best neighborhoods but some that are
you know decent respectable you could
get a duplex in a fine area they're
going to be smaller and usually need
work
um you can you're starting to really
break into the market at that point okay
now what now here's what I'm curious
about where do we go what's the next
level when does it get you into a much
better investment meaning it's not a
sketchy area it's not entry level is it
250 is it 275
yeah I'd say it's around 250. all right
so you're not that far away from that
how much do you make a year
um my wife and I make about 130 combined
okay
yeah so I mean I can tell you Alan yeah
so like the LLC I think is is is a smart
play especially if you're going to have
multiple properties in the next few
years if you've got if you guys you know
look at it and say hey we want we want
this to become part of our wealth
building strategy uh then at that point
you know that's yeah I think that's a
great option very easy to do low lift um
but I would say the two best things to
remember Alan is when you're buying
property you make the most money when
you buy meaning if there's any way which
I know are the market right now is just
crazy but sometimes with those types of
properties that you know I mean if there
is foreclosure short sale any way that
you can get a deal which I know is very
hard right now on the market that we're
in but that's going to be your most
that's going to fast forward your jump
start in this Equity process to get as
much Equity as you can at the buy and I
know you know Dave's rule of thumb with
investment was always I think it's
around like trying to get it at 70 of
value and you having cash is going to be
a really that you're going to that's a
great negotiating tactic that you're
going to have uh to be able just to pay
for it you're not to go through
financing and everything and that's
going to look really appealing so again
any any possible way you can get the
deal and then you know I mean my husband
and I when we our very first one we got
at a as a short sale back 10 years ago
and it was a little yeah uh condo and it
was nasty we went in and got new light
fixtures cleaned it up we rented it for
a few years and then we ended up selling
it to help cash flow the build of our
primary home
um and what it went up you know in just
a few years was was great it was awesome
and so we we sold so just it's kind of
that moving at the speed of cash but the
best the best thing that you can do is
get a deal on the front end Allen and
then yeah if you can see hey I can get a
better deal on something that I know I
can fix up and you're able to put some
money into it uh rent it out making sure
that your tenants doing background
checks I mean like go through that
process so that the renters you have are
as quality that you can get is really
important just to make it as less of a
headache but also know Alan that you're
you're starting a side business in a
sense I mean the the the myth that real
estate is just passive income is
anything but and so you do want to make
sure that it's going to be worth your
time and effort of what the average
rent's going to bring in versus how much
hassle is going to go in I mean you want
to really kind of play out these
scenarios because it's real life they're
going to be calling you you know at 11
o'clock on a Friday night because you
know something broke or whatever it is
right so uh taking all of that into
consideration I just want you to go in
with uh not a uh Pollyanna view which I
feel like some people do sometimes when
it comes yeah and I think he's very
disciplined so Alan I'm not hanging this
on you but I don't want you to get so
excited to get there you've saved 170.
and I know you can get something I'd
rather you save a little bit more and
get something that's that's a much
better bet and that's good yeah and and
to look at your Roi you know what are
you going to get for rent and and all of
that so there's a there's that math play
as well to look at Alan but I think it's
a great and I think I mean real estate I
think isn't is another great Avenue 10
seconds or less building well five
seconds duplex yes or no you like
duplexes it's fine starter first starter
rental there it is she's not mad at him